hey guys it's tim this is my first
video q a experiment let's get it on hey
tim so my question's around
discipline i wanted to ask if you have
any areas that are
just difficult for you to develop
discipline around it seems like you have
incredible habits around journaling
that's a habit that i just have a hard
time tracking
on the journaling do less than than you
think you're capable of doing
so that's number one if you really try
to push it this is true for me too
and then i'll abandon so get the five
minute journal keep it super super
simple just use that for a while
if you can and keep it to five minutes
don't push it and then
as far as discipline routine and all
that oh yeah i struggle all the time
i mean if i don't have systems
incentives if it's not blocked out in my
calendar then
yeah it's gonna i'm gonna struggle with
it i'm
very much human and in that respect and
there are people who are kind of mutants
i'm not one of them if you're trying to
prove to yourself that you can stick
with some type of journaling
practice it doesn't need to be long hand
try the five minute journal hi
tim i noticed that you have a shelf with
what looks like maybe souvenirs back
there
how do you decide which souvenirs to buy
hey there yes you are right you can see
behind me all of these
souvenirs and books and tchotchkes and
so on from various travels and
experiences
the way that i choose those is pretty
simple it's to elicit
a particular feeling or remind me of a
particular
say mantra or principle that i'm trying
to take into my own life so there's
a copy of my friend's book
love yourself like your life depends on
it by kamal robicon and the the
the face of the book is out to remind me
of various things
you can see that that photograph of
milford sound new zealand
which is a feeling of serenity and then
i've got all sorts of stuff
one on the top from japan some things
from mexico those all
elicit particular feelings for me and
that
is the the guiding light or the compass
that i use
to choose things hi tim and let's say if
you meet with your
younger self at a party and you only
have like two
maybe three minutes to talk what advice
would you give him hey man thanks for
the question on the what advice i would
give my younger self
well i mean let's say they're 21 i would
say
you know you can get to the other side
there's darkness in your life
i know you visit it but you can get to
the other side
and find joy and find some degree of
ease
it's not always going to be easy but
like you are going to
be beyond okay and all the things that
you dream about like you'll eventually
be able to do those things
so i would say that number one really
because without hope
all the other tactical strategic stuff
it doesn't matter so like teaching
trying to impart some degree of optimism
would be really important
then i would say meditate meditate every
morning
start now do it twice a day if you can
20 minutes
it's pretty easy i would do that and
then
probably a very cautious recommendation
to
have a conversation about very judicious
supervised use of psychedelics
in the case of acute deep depression or
severe anxiety
so again those have risks they have lots
of legal risks
certainly and psychological
psychoemotional risks so
they're not a free lunch necessarily but
i would i would say those things and
then i mean i always viewed this as kind
of a
cop-out but probably to
explore therapy talk therapy on some
level and i would recommend a few things
like internal family systems and
a couple of other options that i found
useful in the last handful of years
hey tim do you find it hard for people
of
influence or wealth or any amount of
celebrity do you find it hard
for them to get out of their own echo
chambers or to escape
confirmation bias hey there thanks for
the question that's a really good
question really important question
on compromise confirmation bias so
uh i think it's very easy
for anyone not just people with money or
influence but really anyone
who has developed a certain friend group
a certain peer group
to succumb to confirmation bias and just
for people who might be wondering what
that is at least as i understand it it's
really
deciding your beliefs and then having
those reinforced both by your
environment
but specifically looking for evidence
consciously or subconsciously because
you've put a lens on
that reinforces what you already believe
so my closest friends are those people
who are going to stress test
a lot of my positions they're going to
force me to defend a lot of what i
believe
right but belief is just a thought that
we take to be true so
a lot of people within my friend group
let's just say would disagree with one
another about everything
you can imagine so that's
great if you have friends who are
calmly able to strongly disagree with
other people
and to have those conversations it's not
easy and
i think it's very important to be able
to listen to pay attention to someone's
feedback
respectfully to consider it right that's
really important not just read it but
like actually consider it
ask yourself whether it's true and then
not just be open-minded but have
conversely the conviction to stick with
certain beliefs or principles if you
feel like they are very well
founded and supported
and that's [ __ ] tricky it's super
tricky
but if you allow your views and
behaviors and beliefs to be shaped by
feedback on the internet then you're
lost right you're shipped without a
rudder if you don't have some
some type of focus with respect to
principles that you've predetermined
you're gonna use so uh very important
also that when i'm looking at feedback
or presenting anyone else's feedback
i ask myself could i defend this right
like if this were a debate stage
could i really defend this uh and is
this being thought through rationally
right is it rational or is it a fad of
some type there are a lot of fads and
thought
um so hopefully that helps somehow uh
but yes
i think about these things a lot hello
tim this is christopher from
norway about eight years ago i read your
book the four hour work week and i quit
my job
because of it it's the single best
decision i ever made it's led me into
different path
i'm a sound engineer i'm a recording
studio and i'm a
web developer and also a owner of a deli
shop
in a small town in norway and because of
your book
there's a small deli shop located in a
small town in norway
strange my question is uh regarding the
post-production of
your podcast what's the routine like and
do you outsource
the cutting editing the sound the
enhancement
hey man i love the fact that there's a
shop in a small town in norway because
of the book or
more accurately because of what you did
after reading the book so
someday i hope to visit love norway love
love that country
so let's see post production on the
podcast is pretty simple i
record that's usually via zen caster or
squad cast or skype they all have bugs
so i'll just say that in advance none of
them are perfect and then
that will provide audio from both sides
i will record backup audio via quicktime
on the laptop generally using atr 2100
there's a new name
for the newer model that has a usbc
connection so i'm using that
and that's on the production side so now
we have all the files the files go into
dropbox
then that dropbox link will go into
slack there are a few different ways we
do this but i'll go into a slack channel
and the engineer who works on the audio
as well as my producer both in that
channel and
then i will indicate headline options
edits so i'll take notes as we're
recording the podcast
with a guest on things that might need
editing or things that might need
to be removed if especially if they
request things and then
that those files are immediately sent to
transcription
so that the transcript can be put into a
google doc so that if my producer has
any suggested edits
or any questions for me those can all be
added into a google doc those get
approved
and i find those tasks because they're
added to asana by the producer
and that's about
it but sometimes there are things for me
to approve beforehand and those will all
go into asana to get my attention
and then off it goes into the interwebs
hey tim as i'm moving more into a
managerial role
in my full-time work as well as having
very serious hobbies of
jiu-jitsu and cooking i'm having
difficulty striking that balance
of creating more than you consume and i
was just curious to hear if you had any
additional frameworks or strategies or
ways of approaching
the create consume issue
amen so a couple things on creating
and counterbalancing the managing i
would say
with the jiu jitsu there's a lot of
creativity there
certainly you could check out i mean you
would be consuming on one hand
but it would be in the service of
creating anything online by marcelo
garcia's academy
which was co-founded with josh waitzkin
i know they are probably not
doing any classes currently but you can
see back catalog
and it's thematically organized to buy
transition position technique etc
so you can see some amazing stuff
especially in sparring for the
cooking i mean this seems
self-interested but for our chef has a
lot of experimentation that you can add
in
and what's nice about the
experimentation in the four-hour chef is
that
it's intended to teach you principles
and tools you may be already super
advanced if so this might not apply but
it teaches you both kind of the grammar
and the idiom and the vocabulary of
cooking in a way that allows you to then
take those things and translate them
all over the place to different cuisines
so that could be fun to experiment with
the very least check out the egg part
which allows you to learn the flavor
combinations
of different regions and countries
that's pretty easy and pretty fun
so i'll just give that to you as a
starting point hi tim
my question is about your research with
psychedelics
and the narrative around psychedelics
the data will speak for itself on
whether they work
but it seems like with your your
firepower on marketing
it could be uh great for the cause to
put some of that
behind it to help change that narrative
and get the word out
howdy so on the psychedelic front thanks
so much for the kind words i'm very very
excited about certainly the scientific
side and as things scale
as you have the experiences
and certainly administration of these
compounds going from
thousands to tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands possibly let's say
in any given
year right or even any given month then
there are going to be bad things that
happen that's just the way
that the laws of big numbers work so i
think
what's going to be very very important
is getting insurance on board to both
lower the costs
and also assess risk because that will
be part of
the process for
evaluating anything for insurance
coverage there also needs to be
self-policing and
that that means trade organizations or
just uh
organizations could be non-profit that
help to ensure
that best practices are followed right
so there could be
incentives and public pressure through
organizations that would bring together
say clinics of different types and i'm
sure these exist for ketamine but
across the board this will be more and
more important since if you don't want
regulations
to crack down then you need to
self-police
and you need to have structures in place
and incentives in place
that help ensure people are being their
their best selves organizationally and
personally and as practitioners so
hopefully that makes sense i'm going to
do my best
and thanks for the video hi jim you've
spoken a couple times recently about
the importance of having more
self-compassion i was wondering if you
had found any particular
techniques or practices that had helped
you develop more
self-compassion or self-worth or
self-love hey andy
yes self-compassion self-love is a work
in progress
and there are practices and tools i
would say
radical acceptance the book by tara
brock is very very helpful
i would say that if you have access to
an internally internal
family systems ifs therapist that's also
very very helpful
but i would read radical acceptance
first and then
loving-kindness meditation directed at
younger versions of yourself it's often
difficult to give
compassion to our current day selves
it's often easier i would say
to rewind the clock and give it to
yourself when you were young perhaps
when you didn't get something that you
needed the support the love whatever it
might be
or when you were going through a really
tough time it's a lot easier to
extend compassion sometimes to the
earlier versions of ourselves and then
we can
slowly work to the present day and
i have found it really helpful once
you've developed
that visualization practice to take 10
20 seconds
and to extend love to a
younger version of yourself say a
childhood version
when you have your meals just close your
eyes for a minute and treat it as a
grace
and that way it's not something new
you're adding to your schedule it's
it's in effect piggybacking on top of
something you're gonna do anyway which
is eat
three times a day or so depending on
what your rhythm is hope that helps
hey tim it's mark gunther from maryland
thank you for raising
money for the maps capstone challenge i
wanted to ask you what kind of obstacles
you ran into as you tried to persuade
people to donate to help maps
make mdma into a medicine to what degree
do you find there still
is a stigma surrounding psychedelics
thanks a lot
hey mark it's good to see you and thanks
for all your coverage of
the psychedelic science space i would
say in terms of challenges in raising
money for the capstone campaign
right so ultimately whatever it was 30
million bucks the challenges
were on one hand specific to mdma
because of its history
of use as ecstasy in a recreational
context
a drug of potential abuse which many
people
don't realize was actually preceded by
its use therapeutically
under code name adam for quite some time
in the underground
there is that association that needed to
be overcome for some of the
organizations involved to ultimately
commit and be very very supportive
there were otherwise really only the
challenges that you face when raising
money for non-profits
and for non-profit causes especially
from business folks
a lot of them like to make money and
will either give you the line that you
know for-profit market-driven solutions
are going to be the best solution
although i think maps does a good job of
that
with their uh pharmaceutical development
co
and uh you know if they claim you know
one tip is if a billionaire tells you
that they have liquidity issues
that just means they don't want to do it
and you shouldn't waste your breath
trying to convince them otherwise move
on to the next person
so there you have it but ultimately it
was a lot easier than expected
curious about your thoughts on your own
kind of past upbringing maybe even your
trauma
how any of that is really connected to
the fact that you really [ __ ] more
towards being an individual performer
whether that's
wrestling or martial arts tango your
business
really kind of as a solopreneur that you
are really more comfortable as the
individual performer hey thanks for the
question yeah but i think for sure
it's possible that the
[Music]
uh upbringing being the oldest child uh
being also a runt when i was growing up
so
the sports that were available to me
were mostly individual it wasn't
necessarily byproduct of trauma just
really small so doing something like
football or soccer or whatever was
gonna be a nightmare but i did do soccer
for a bunch of years i enjoyed the team
sports
what i did not enjoy was the ability
for anyone on the team to blame other
people for say
a loss or to give themselves unfair
credit for a win
so i like the accountability of the
individual sports
as far as guest skill a lot of the folks
i'm interviewing are
are parts of big teams but i'm
generally more of a lone operator
generally speaking that's just where i
am most comfortable i'm also highly
introverted
so i think that has something to do with
it i'm
very much depleted by lots of
social interaction or large groups some
people
like my girlfriend are energized they're
the opposite they're the extrovert
energizer bunnies but that's just not me
hey there tim
we just purchased a new home me and my
wife and uh
i just realized that we're slightly
south of the
flight of the airplanes they come out of
the airport and it's kind of loud
i'm pretty bummed i didn't do more
research in this area any hacks for
using
uh stuff to make your bedroom quieter at
night when you sleep
sleep and blocking out noise or
overwriting noise in a sense i think
about this a lot i'm very sensitive to
sound
so there are a few tools i can recommend
that i found particularly helpful the
marpac
dome dohm is a white noise machine that
i found very helpful some people use
an iphone and a
noise app to generate white noise or
brown noise which some people prefer
i use the marpac dome i find it to
provide more
of a soothing fan type of quality
if cold air isn't an issue you could
always point it outside the doorway
a fan actually a very cheap 20 fan
that is pointing out the door can also
be helpful i
use mac m-a-c-k
silicone earplugs if i really need to
sleep
i find this to be more comfortable than
the
conventional foam earplugs which
tend to be very uncomfortable if i turn
onto my side
whereas the mac which you can also use
for swimming i find to conform very
nicely to the side of the head
hey tim my question is about questions
how do you collect your questions and
then from there how do you test your
questions do you
deliberately try them out in
conversation with friends and loved ones
how do they then go from that testing
stage to
okay i'm going to try this in a podcast
hey david yeah i think a lot about
questions i love questions i
typically record questions and i come
across them in conversation or elsewhere
in notes
first natively on the phone and then i
will often
take them and copy them over into
evernote or
increasingly i'll be using rome rome
research i don't really test them out on
friends and family
i will very often just jump into the hot
water with a podcast guest and test it
out because
i rarely record live in front of any
type of audience which means if it
doesn't work
we can just cut it out in
post-production what i've found over
time also
is that it's important to take note of
questions that work
and questions that don't but if you ask
especially a really good
follow-up question they give an answer
what did you learn from that
right or they give you an answer how did
that make you feel what was it like when
a b
c happened right these types of very
simple follow-up questions
can really yield a lot of gold and in
some ways the follow-ups are more
important than the
openers hi tim i'm 25 years old i'm here
in ireland i'm planning on completely
re-skilling
myself and going into different fields
what's your advice on the process of
re-skilling
re-skilling it's not it's not a term i'm
terribly familiar with but i think i do
get the basic idea
i think the best time to explore new
terrain is very often when you are
gainfully employed you could
potentially look at consulting with
one or more startups or working for free
for
one or more startups for a period of
time in addition to your current work
if you're in a fast-growing area you
will begin to get
first-hand appreciation of what skills
are valued there are certain fundamental
skills that really magnify everything
else you might do
writing really well and speaking really
well
so i would say you could look at you
know ai
and different types of coding and so on
but as a human
really really skilled or skillful
speaking and writing
is going to get you a lot further than
you might expect it's a multiplier for
everything else you might do
hey tim what has been your journey so
far in
opening up being vulnerable and sharing
your depression with your girlfriend
so the first thing i would say is
actually something that i picked up
from my first podcast with brene brown
where we were talking about
trust and the nature of developing trust
and she said people think
that you earn trust first and then you
offer vulnerability
second if you lead with vulnerability
that develops
trust and increases the bond of trust
between you so
i've often had the questions that you
have right how do i talk to my
girlfriend about this i'm just afraid
that this this and this and i know
that's an unreasonable fear and it's
kind of silly but
i just don't know how to talk to her
about it and i was working with a coach
and i said something like that to him
and he said
why don't you just say that to your
girlfriend and i was like oh
yeah good advice also real quick
non-violent communication the work by
byron katie imago dialogue and couples
therapy
check all of those out hey tim my
question is regarding your relationship
you mentioned to kevin rose that you
schedule to have deeper conversations
you batch
and so it's not just coming up whenever
it comes up i love that
my question is in the moment when it
comes up where do you put the feelings
how do you have any tips or tools as
how to handle those moments hey katie
one of the techniques that we both use
is simply making an appointment so when
something comes up we will ask when
would be a good time
to have a chat or may i make an
appointment
to chat about a few things that are on
my mind so then you have a set
point in time when you know you'll be
discussing these things
another tool in the toolkit is byron
katie's the work
there are certain exercises that you can
use as well as morning pages to kind of
defuse
or at least in some ways deconstruct
your own beliefs before you bring them
to your partner hey tim my question is
how do you figure out where to live
i'm thinking about moving to a new city
i was wondering if you have any
experience
or knowledge in figuring out which
factors carry the most
weight when looking to move somewhere
new a good place to start i think is
asking yourself
why do i want to leave where i am
currently rather than pick a full-time
destination you might look at how you
could test drive
a number of different locations for say
at least two weeks just enough to see
some variations in weather for instance
and
to give yourself a chance to explore and
get a feel for the personality of the
cities of course there are a lot of
popular places right now
tons of folks moving to florida tons of
folks moving
to say colorado to nashville
there's a long list the third coast
austin texas certainly is popular
and i feel like half of los angeles is
here already i would encourage you to
also look at
which factors that are compelling you to
move
are internal versus external so there
may be things
to work on that otherwise will follow
you to wherever your next destination is
hey tim franz here you talk a lot about
uh
hallucinogens uh psilocybe and and so
forth
and here in austria where i am it's very
hard to find
places or people who can do guided
sessions with yourself my wife
is working in the mobile palliative care
team here in salzburg and
i think they'd be really interested in
trying this out
uh at the end of of patients lives
and so i was just wondering what would
be your advice uh
how could i go about finding someone in
my area
since you're so connected in this field
uh i'd be very grateful
for your advice thanks man hey friends i
would have to know a lot more
about the specifics on the ground uh and
also i can't really give too much advice
certainly on this channel related to
something that might be
against the norms legally speaking where
you are but there are a few
things i might look into so i would
consider looking at
ketamine ketamine may be a legal option
at least it is in much of the united
states
where some of the other psychedelics are
not
and ketamine can be used in both
non-psychedelic and psychedelic doses
even though it's
known predominantly as an anesthetic hi
tim
my question is if there were one podcast
episode or one book of yours that you
would want your audience to share with
someone who has never heard of you
before
what would that be it depends on what
your objective is if you want to get
them hooked and
what their likes and dislikes are but i
would say a few that immediately come to
mind if you want to try to hook someone
would be jamie foxx the first episode i
did with him
elizabeth gilbert also extremely
extremely strong
or mary car both of those i think are
strong in some similar ways those would
be a few to start with hey tam this is
andrew from
colorado just wondering when we can
expect your next book
andrew as far as the next book goes i am
strongly contemplating putting together
a book on my healing
journey which certainly would include
many
of the excursions into non-ordinary
states of consciousness
which would include psychedelics it
would include
other let's just call it modalities as
well and one of the challenges
for me is determining how to write such
a book
about direct experiences some of which
seem to defy any
western rational scientific
explanation at least for the time being
put another way how do i write this book
without seeming
like a total [ __ ] raving lunatic
or maybe i don't care and i throw
caution to the wind and just
show my true colors we shall see so tbd
hey tim i've got a couple of questions
related to hiv training and resonance
breathing one of my professional
backgrounds is at the intersection of
ai and digital art and music i'm just
really curious if you
practiced with music or with soundscapes
or used anything like that in your
training or practice and i know you
talked a lot about how you struggle with
thermal regulation
i have the same problem i'd love to hear
if you had any
improvements with your firmer regulation
for hiv training
or also if you have any other resources
or things that recently helped you with
the thermal regulation
hey max i did a 10-week program under dr
lialagos and i worked with her directly
we did experiment with music so with a
respiration strap
and a pulse oximeter we would do these
live sessions together
and identify different types of music
that would affect
my resonance and found a number of songs
including a few from santana that seemed
to do the trick for me personally of
course it's very very individualized
on thermal regulation i would say
what has helped the most is probably
my new setup from a company called eight
sleep i found
their technology to be very easy to use
easy to set up
and consistently effective at helping me
with
sleep on set which is typically when i
feel it most severely and when it has
the most negative impact
on my quality of life is when i take a
really long time to get to sleep or
can't stay asleep
you